the backwards baseball cap the  sunglasses the punny name this is  Lucille mascot for the San Francisco  Giants before they had Luke the Jazz did  something well a little crazy it was  1984 and the Giants weren't just bad  they were awful to offset the team's  losing streak  they created an anti mascot the crazy  crab so fans would have something other  than the team to hate and it actually  worked  but the love-hate relationship quickly  turned into a hate hate relationship  things get out of hand the fans and even  players start throwing things at the  crazy crap due to safety issues  the Giants pulled a crazy crab anti  mascot for good this is where the  lovable anti anti mascot comes in  Lucille was born on Farallon Island he's  a Bay Area native and one cool dude he's  universally beloved and a crowd favorite  a far cry from the anti mascot formerly  known as crazy crab